hi i'm ryan and i'm gonna
react to the trailer of old boy
i don't know [ __ ] about this movie
except that josh brolin's in it
good universe
that's sexy
it's like saw
hello hello it's like saw meets that
movie but john keeps that
hey tell me why i'm in there look at me
the body of donna hawthorne was
discovered the prime suspect
joseph ducette the victim's former
husband
and father damn he's such a good actor
i'm gonna watch it just go down
your father's been missing for 20 years
if i could somehow bring jesus christ
with the crucifix in the background
symbolism
i could try looks like rob zombie
actually
spike lee woo he's winning tarantino
what happened then he showed up last
night that's totally how i'd want to
come back from the dead i haven't seen
the guy in like 20 years
where are you if you were trying to find
your daughter
and clear your name i could help you if
you would like to see your daughter
alive again
answer two questions yeah guys
why did i imprison you for 20 years
and two why did i let you go
oh [ __ ]
damn
yeah sex
i don't want you to go i don't have a
choice
whoever you are i will find
you oh that's exciting
i totally run this place all right
[ __ ] you might want to think about what
you're doing here i've been thinking
about it for the last 20 years
well they just gave away that samuel
jackson dies that's
that's awesome i like a movie that's
kind of just a straightforward revenge
tale
and uh i it's i read this story the
other day about a woman
who was like since she was i don't know
like eight or something was kept in a
dungeon by her dad for like 20 years
it's
a horrifying story so i can actually
believe the plot of this
is someone being kidnapped for 20
mysterious years now it looks violent
and josh brown looks like it gives an
awesome performance
it looks a little familiar but whatever
i'm gonna go check it out
you